und jetzt kommt mein heutiger
kabarettgast er hat eigentlich Biologie
studiert ist also Wissenschaftler und
ich bin ja auch Wissenschaftler ihr plus
rausgefunden
doch doch eins habe ich rausgefunden
nämlich dass er ein grandioser
Kabarettist ist meine Damen und Herren
der wunderbare einzigartige Philipp
Weber
[Musik]
also die Welt stürmt immer schneller
voran schneller schneller schneller
Automatisierung Technisierung
Digitalisierung natürlich
Digitalisierung ein Drittel der
Deutschen fühlen sie von der
Digitalisierung vollkommen überfordert
geht mir genauso Handy wenn ich ein
neues Handy habe dann muss ich wie
Heinrich der fette nach Canossa zu
meinem Neffen pilgern ja damit der mir
das Handy einrichtet und der kann ist
vier Jahre alt
ein Freund von mir der hat nicht nur ein
Smartphone sondern auch noch ein Smart
Home ein intelligentes Heim er drei
Putzroboter sie kennen diese Putzroboter
ein zum Boden putzen ein zum Fenster
putzen und einen zum Rasenmähen habe ich
da was heißt der Rasenmähen du wohnst im
11 Stock
ja er lässt jetzt einmal täglich im
Stadtpark raus
er hat sogar eine intelligente Toilette
ohne Witz eine intelligente Toilette
wenn man die Tür aufmacht geht erstmal
Musik an da da da da da da da da da da
da ja die Toilette ist so intelligent
Welt die Musik passend zur Peristaltik
haha bei Verstopfung Wagner bei
Dünnpfiff Zauberflöte
aber sonst ist alles dran ja aber
heizbarer sitzt Multimedia Touchscreen
und nach dem Akt bekommt man mit einer
massagedüse warmes Wasser gegen den
Hintern gespritzt und dann mit einem
analfön die Poperze sanft trocken
geputzt
und ich muss sagen es ist saugeil
es ist wirklich saugeil aber ich habe
gesagt Konrad es kann alles sein dass
ich wegen sinnlicher Entrückung von der
Toilette überhaupt nicht mehr
runterkommen ja aber die Digitalisierung
unseres Lebens geht oder viel viel
weiter hat er gesagt er hätte eine neue
Freundin ob ich sie kennenlernen Willi
kennenlernen wie heißen sie denn
endoline endoline ist aber ein schöner
Name hat die endoline irgendwie
Migrationshintergrund hat sie gesagt ja
sie ist eine baumelfe aus Mittelerde
was eine baumelfe redest du irgendwie
von von Rollenspielen hat er gesagt nein
VR virtuelle Realität des Internets ja
vollkommen neues sexuelle Möglichkeiten
er hat gesagt er hat eine
Internetplattform gefunden der kann man
in und mit 300 verschiedenen Körpern
sexuelle Interaktion haben was du gehst
in dem Internet sagen
ja genau so kann man sagen
hat er gesagt alles was man dafür
braucht ist eine VR Brille die kennen
Sie vielleicht oder so eine VR Brille
und schnallt euch an ein VR genitalker
noch mal
ein wirklicher hat mich gefragt ich
möchte das nicht ausprobieren weil genau
an so einem Teil habe ich mir vor 30
Jahren beinahe gesagt abgerissen
hat er gesagt wieso da gab es noch keine
VR genitalkircher nee aber Staubsauger
hat schon keine
und ich weiß was sie denken sie denken
die gesellschaftliche Relevanz ich sage
Ihnen wo die Gesellschaft die relevant
ist laut homo digitale Studie das
Fraunhofer Institutes können sich ein
Drittel der Deutschen vorstellen mit
einem Sexroboter zu schlafen mit einem
600 oder bitte aber das hat nichts mit
diesem Plastikpuppen von früher zu tun
ihr wisst schon wo es vor Spiel daraus
bestand dass man seine Sexualpartnerin
erstmal aufpusten musste
das sind Blastomere geliebte perfekte
menschliche Abbildungen körperwarmen
gefühlsecht und mit denen kann man sogar
reden aber was zur Hölle will ich denn
mit einer Sexpuppe reden und dolly ist
der Tag gewesen na wie soll mein Tag
gewesen sein ich lag unter dem Bett in
meinem Karton
du nimmst mich raus wo willst du denn
hin du könntest mich deinen Kollegen
vorstellen ich kann nicht damit zur
Arbeit nehmen ja weiblich für mich
schämst ach Dolly lange nicht an
ich meine ich verstehe das Prinzip
dahinter auch nicht oder ich meine wenn
die Jungs die Sexpuppen haben
tatsächlich mit Frauen reden könnten
dann bräuchte du wahrscheinlich gar
keine selbst Bomben oder ich meine
schaut mich an ich bin wahrlich kein Don
Juan aber ich habe auch jemand
abbekommen und warum weil ich reden kann
ich kann reden ja das sollen die Männer
da draußen bloß nicht unterschätzen man
muss nicht immer schön sein manchmal
reicht schon die Macht des hartnäckigen
Bettelns danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]